[Música]
creo que el proyecto del tren maya no me
gusta llamarle maya porque no es nada de
maya ni tiene nada de maya y al
contrario es un proyecto etnocida
ecocida este famoso el trenecito cuando
empezó a entrar ahora sí fue una
imposición una imposición sumamente
dolorosa porque llega de buenas a
primeras hace dos años aproximadamente
que te vas porque te vas y te estás
viendo digo es un atropello
[Música]
una tristeza de qué
y que sigamos igual
después
todos los proyectos brincan campeche
de villahermosa o sea de tabasco yucatán
o punto amargo
y cuando nos dan la oportunidad
pues no la aprovechamos
[Música]